good morning this is ian king live an
hour of business and economic news from
the heart of the city
sky the parent company of sky news was
named yesterday
as the principal partner and media
partner for the cop 26 international
climate change summit
taking place in glasgow this november
the news came the sky which has already
set a target of
ambition to being net zero carbon by
2030
and has new environmental commitments
for its productions
well sky's executive chairman jeremy
darreck stepped down last week as chief
executive after more than a decade in
the job
and he joins me now jeremy derrick
morning to you why was it so important
for sky to become
partner to cop 26. 26.
well the annual u.n climate change
conference which is cop
is particularly important this year i
think for a few reasons first of all
because we we need to reignite progress
around the globe and particularly coming
out of
uh curved and some light at the end of
the tunnel to build back economy
sustainably and
and in a way that's going to be protect
the environment and value the
environment of course we've got a change
in u.s administration we know that's
going to be
an important part of their agenda but
also in the uk uh the government's been
clear that it's going to be much
much more central to uk's economic
policies so this is a particularly
important year
the cop 26 summit will be here in the uk
and so we want to do our bit we want to
play a role
uh using our platform to explain that to
all of our viewers and customers
and really draw attention to the
importance of the moment i think
now you've really driven the climate
agenda during your time at the helm of
sky has that come
at the cost of profitability
no uh uh quite the opposite actually i
think it's been
something that we've been able to figure
out in a way that's consistent with
growing our profits over that that whole
period and when you sort of think about
that and distill it down
it is i think because at its essence
being sustainable and environmentally
efficient and responsible is actually
about consuming resources
in a better more efficient way and so
there's no reason that this can draw
with growing profits actually can be
something
that can help drive profitability as we
find better more efficient ways of
consuming
the planet's resources which we get
essentially for free
and what about the undertakings that
were announced yesterday on productions
how measurable will progress be
very measurable and this is really
important actually raises an important
point there's no good
uh us pursuing these things if we don't
uh we don't measure them we measure them
independently we're properly audited we
can't audit you know we can't mark our
own homework so central to all of our
plans has been that
how do we properly measure the progress
we're making
or where we're falling behind our own
goals and then how do we encourage the
industry to introduce the sort of
standards
that are going to make sure that
everybody can move forward at the right
pace so
underpinning the new production
standards that we're all adhering to
is a set of principles called the albert
principles uh they've been
developed through bafta and they'll be a
central part uh to that it's really very
very important that we
that we that we audit and we monitor
robustly the progress we're making do
you think it's
time that businesses like sky elsewhere
in the industry
had mandatory targets of this sort
i'm never personally a huge fan of
forcing mandatory targets on the
business because my experience is when
you get into individual businesses
you know everything gets very slightly
different and businesses are different
stages of development and challenge but
we've got to make progress
we've got a target in the uk to be a
essentially a carbon
free economy a carbon neutral economy by
2050 at sky we're going to be net zero
common by 2030 so fully 20 years ahead
of that
so i think ultimately a business can't
get in front of this and we know it's so
important
to uh to customers to citizens of of
of the uk uh you know we're gonna have
to uh increase the pressure i think but
hopefully
we're not there and the businesses can
get at the forefront of this
and can lead the way now looking at the
sky
business more broadly obviously the
company was taken over by comcast just
over two years ago
has the takeover changed the way you've
been managing the business particularly
one of the things i was struck right
from the outset is just what how much in
common we have with with comcast
essentially
both of the businesses wake up every
morning to do the same they do do the
same things we're very very customer
focused
we're essentially facing the same
challenges and opportunities uh
throughout the world so
i don't think it's changed enormously uh
what we what we've we've done we found
that the
the the environment we could plug into
uh is is an environment we're familiar
with and we like
and increasingly now what we're starting
to do is we're starting to work on
solutions and opportunities that will
affect the total company
so i can think of some of the product
development work we're doing for example
uh skies now tv streaming platform was
the backbone to peacock that's
nbc universal's uh big ott streaming
launch in
in in the us and we're working across
the broader
uh content group to create more global
content so
um it's it's it's i think supercharged
what we're doing rather than
required us to change a huge amount of
basic operating practice
you mentioned now tv just then i mean
that's one of a number of products that
sky's launched during a time as chief
executive others were sky plus sky hd
sky q
was there any of these that were more
significant than the others in terms of
driving growth
i think the the biggest i think was our
move to a high definition
platform um some time ago now um for
for a few reasons we really moved the
whole industry not just in the uk
uh into europe into high definition but
importantly
we started to distribute content over
our broadband network as well as using
uh the satellite internally that really
marked the point where we stopped being
a linear broadcaster really became a a
technology business a multi-platform
business
and much of what we've done since then
has has connected to that
to that to that start of the journey and
the bit i liked about it at the time of
course
was that was right at the heart of the
financial crisis many people were then
saying well how would sky survive in
that world and of course we thrived by
doing that by embracing customer trends
by pushing into those uh we can't we
went on a journey of growth
that has really continued to this day so
that's probably been the single most
important thing of many that we've done
just to pick up on something you said
there
do you see sky more now as a technology
company rather than as a media and
entertainment company
the really three pillars that this
business is is built around today
technology and products is definitely
one big pillar we are
you know we have a huge technology uh
workplace we employ thousands of
engineers now right across the business
then a big content business we're a much
bigger owned content business so things
like sky studios sky originals
are an ever-growing part of our business
and we're a scale content producer today
which
you know 10 years ago we was unthinkable
and and that's a big area of growth
and then the final bit of our business
is about customer service
how can we be the best customer service
provider and never lose sight
that the people that judge the success
of this business or the people are our
customers the people who pay us day in
day out so
today if you looked at sky i think you
would see those three things
uh going through the business like like
a thread through a stick of rock they're
the three things that we really build
the business on
and what about the competitor landscape
obviously netflix have been around for a
while now but disney plus has just
launched you've also got virgin media
trying to buy o2 for example there's a
lot going on in the sector
yeah i mean all was has always will i
suspect it's a very very vibrant sector
it's a sector of course characterized by
really not very many barriers to entry
pretty much today if you want to get
your content
to somebody it's it's easy and getting
easier to do that
so it's a very vibrant thriving sector
but big picture
when you stand back from that it's one
of the reasons why the whole sector and
the business continues to grow there are
just more services today that we can
offer for customers
video is becoming a much more important
part of people's lives day in
day out now the other thing that's
happening i think is it's becoming a bit
more complicated if you're a customer
there are so many different choices and
of course that's
that's a key role that sky can play can
make it easy for you
it can aggregate or we do aggregate all
of these services so
the likes of disney plus on netflix or
amazon prime or discovery or the bbc
are all available on your sky platform
with just you know one push of your
remote control
almost almost a button click within a
button click of desire if you like
uh and and that's that's that's very
powerful because it takes a complicated
world for customers
and says we'll just we'll just we'll
just take care of it and we'll make it
easy for you
now what about your position your
executive chairman until the end of the
year you're remaining as an advisor but
uh after that
are you looking for another executive
role perhaps
uh no you know i've got to figure out
what i'm gonna what i'm gonna do next
it's not it's not my plan to do another
executive role i want to take some time
to have a
you know an impact hopefully in a
slightly wider sense
to work on some of the passions to keep
involved in you know areas like the
environment and
and other things so so i'm going to
figure that out that's one of the things
i'm going to do
alongside you know betting in my new my
successor dana strong i think it's going
to be fantastic
uh into the business and then advising
the company you know across
across the globe really around what what
we do and
and elevating if you like my
contribution to a different level but
that's
just at the start of that journey all
right jeremy darrow really good to talk
to you this morning thanks very much for
joining me